thank you guys shaq mamadiarov with us
here in the studio
not much happened today or did we miss
something
of course
today i just want to play very solid
because
i lost yesterday very bad game
after i lose game i every time
i don't know
i can to lose after three more games and
i know myself and i just want to play
solid chess but i don't want to play
solid like
today but
i just want to play for two results draw
or win but
it was no
not any chance to play for win
and i just take g7
i mean i i want to play very solid draw
and at this moment
eliza take knight g5 i think okay i will
take also
if you
give his knight but i can take three
pawn but after bishop g7 if sixth i
start to think how to play draw now
and he was playing very quickly it
seemed like he was still within
preparation uh
no no no
maximum is of course
i remember this position but
i mean i i know
this typical position take f6 but of
course
black is okay i just
try to play not miss
anything yesterday i played really bad
game i mean not very bad i just played
very bad
move a5
and after this i lost very easily and
today i just want to play very solid
talk a little bit about yesterday's game
we were a little surprised about your
decision in the opening to play this
move b6 instead of the normal b5 what
was your thought process there okay
i just want to play for
of course for win and
it was a good chance good position to
play an interesting move
you can't play b6 or
any move because where humans is easy to
miss in
in in these typical positions
i just play b6 of course i remember this
b5 move but eb5 is uh
he played very fast queen e3 of course
b5 he was preparing well i just want to
play b6 and just to play chess i mean
b6 is just to play chess i mean of
course i think 10 minutes prefer to play
b6 or not but it is move a5 it also
shocked me because a5 is back inside of
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah because you know it's like i
i i think i i'm not his disposition
is and my
uh when you say analyze this position
you mean like prep or you during the
game yeah yeah no no no no event is
after queen e3 this problem says queen
e3 move back queen e3 yeah uh inside
queen e3
if not play queen e3 is white can play
is one of the best queen g3 here
and rookie 8 bishop d3 queen e6 rookie
one b5 the same position
yeah i remember this position of course
so you actually got it from
transposition yeah especially i remember
it's my home preparation of the b5
because quincy iii it is bad move after
coin g3 i can play b5 is the minimum um
is black is very good puzzle i remember
this is my analysis and i i remembered
all everything here till the b4 b3
everything
but is i remember is
move b3 yeah everything take bishop one
rookie one when i analyze this position
we analyzed in board without in jain i
mean we announced this position and i
speak with my friend of course he say
you need push a5 a4 but after
i remember he said it is bad idea
the game i immediately okay i mean you
say of course this looks like a human a5
a4 but
of course i remember this one a5 a4 is
looks nice but after i remember this is
like a very bad idea but i played a5 of
course d6 i just calculated
i mean two means the sixth move here the
sixth take take
and rookie three i think this is a very
bad position for black because of very
strong attack queen is for rook g3 i
absolutely missed d5 move here and there
are 55 yeah after the d5 is
very good position is close to win for
black
but i absolutely missed d5 and after d5
his white is no attack i just
did miss and i played a5 as absolutely
because i remember this move in our
knowledge a5 but after
uh as a game i check and say yes a5
inaudible is bad move
it is just bad move yeah chuck three
rounds already gone in the sing field
cup how do you feel your form here of
course i'm not very happy with my
results but
it's very strong tournament and it's
everything can happen here i mean you
can lose
also
many many games it's not first it's not
last
and
i know
[Music]
every day is
i can lose and i can win and of course
for this reason when you play in this
tournament is
the
most important to think is life is
beautiful
and
as you know you need to just think
everything is good and you just play in
this super tournament you must be very
happy to be here and to lose or to win
okay is
obviously is is possibility every day i
mean to lose a
game and
to win for me it's lose
one game or two games or three games is
not surprising me i mean it's absolutely
normal and for this reason i am ready
more
for more games for fighting chess more
interesting chess and also for more uh
results i mean to win or tools well
always on a good mood and hopefully you
don't lose two or three games we want to
see you win in that crazy attacking
style that you have thanks for joining
us and good luck in the rest of your
games thank you thank you very much
indeed check don't worry be happy